>>Reto Meier: Good afternoon, everyone, and
welcome to the Friday App Review.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm joined by Fred Chung.
>>Fred Chung: Good afternoon.
>>Meier: We're going to take a look at some
apps today.
We asked you guys for some suggestions for
recipe apps, and you did not give us any.
Which means one of two things: either you
guys don't like recipe apps, or there aren't
any recipe apps.
>>Chung: There was such an overwhelming crowd.
>>Meier: Yes.
[laughs] You just couldn't pick from amongst
the very many good ones.
>>Chung: There are just too many.
>>Meier: Apparently so.
So what we're going to do this week instead
is have a look at some of our favorites.
Fred's got a couple of food related apps.
Which ones are you going to take a look at
today?
>>Chung: Yeah.
We're going to have a look at My Food and
BigOven.
>>Meier: Excellent.
The reason I was asking you guys for recipe
apps was because I didn't know of any goods
ones.
So rather than spend time looking at apps
I've never looked at before, I'm going to
take a look at some of my favorite apps, in
terms of apps that I use a lot of.
And that's Series Guide, IMDb, and, if we
get time, I'm going to take a look at TripIt
as well.
Now, before we get started, I just want to
clarify a little bit about what we're trying
to achieve here at the Friday App Review.
Unlike a lot of the review shows that you
may have seen, we're not really focused on
giving a fair and balanced evaluation of what
are some great apps that we think you guys
should be installing.
We're part of a developer relations team here
at Android.
Our focus is really on trying to help developers
build better apps.
So to do that, whenever we look at these apps,
we're really trying to dissect them, take
them apart, see what they're doing right,
see what they're doing wrong, and really try
and create a learning experience so that other
app developers can learn from the mistakes
and successes of these other apps.
Really, the app review doesn't make a lot
of sense as a title, so we're actually going
to change the name of our show live on air.
So from this point on, we're going to become
the Friday App Clinic.
Now, in order to maintain that new branding,
I have some props.
I'm going to just get off camera and get my
props.
[shuffling noises]
>>Chung: Reto's going to come back soon.
[laughs]
>>Meier: [laughs] Don't panic.
[more shuffling] And Daniel, if our producer
off camera can also switch our title, so that
we can become the Friday App Clinic, that
would be fantastic.
>>Chung: We have double to size of our production
team.
>>Meier: [laughs] That's right.
Twice as many producers.
>>Off-camera engineer: Oh, did you remember
to tell your off-camera engineer to include
your new title in his title set?
>>Meier: Yes.
[laughs] One moment.
That's all right, we have all the time in
the world.
I have my--
>>Off-camera engineer: You have an hour.
>>Meier: I have an hour.
>>Off-camera engineer: Actually, more like
45 minutes.
>>Chung: We have 45 minutes.
That's close to an hour.
>>Meier: 45 minutes?!
Oh, then we should get this shit sorted out.
All right.
We have our doctor Droids.
I have my lab coat.
>>Chung: You have a lab coat.
Where's mine?
>>Meier: You have to bring your own coat.
>>Chung: I have to order it.
>>Meier: Yeah.
I mean, come on, man!
>>Chung: That's what that box was for.
>>Meier: Absolutely.
You need to order your own equipment.
>>Chung: Just pretend this is a white--
>>Meier: This is a white coat.
Absolutely.
>>Chung: Can you color correct it?
>>Meier: Color correct it.
Yeah, you should have worn at least a green
shirt, so we can make due.
>>Chung: Next time, maybe.
>>Meier: That's right.
That's right.
I snuck this up on Fred here, as well.
This is his first clinic too.
So I can be the official clinician.
[laughs] And Fred can continue to be a reviewer.
So let's get started.
Let's have a look at one of your apps.
Let's start with--.
Where would you like to start?
>>Chung: Yeah.
I'm excited to stick to something that is
related to recipes.
Both of these apps, as I mentioned earlier,
my Food and BigOven-- if we could switch to
the tablet, please.
Both of these apps try to tackle the problem
where you're trying to figure out what's for
dinner.
Then you have to figure out what kind of dishes
you would like to get.
After the preparation stage, you can translate
the types of ingredients into some sort of
shopping list.
These two apps try to solve this problem.
They try to do it a little bit differently.
Why don't we have a look at my Food?
As soon as this app is launched, it's pretty
self-explanatory.
It's got three high level menu items that
you can pick from: shopping list, recipes,
and meal planner.
All of these, very prominently displayed,
which is nice, which makes it very easy for
users to comprehend.
You would go into recipe first, but before
diving into the content of recipe, I like
to highlight that when I tap on any of these
targets, there's no touch feedback.
I would, like what we've been asking developers
to do.
When you come up with graphics icons, be sure
to have different, have them represented in
different states to represent the natural
state, focus state, and pressed state.
>>Meier: That's really important, particularly
for accessibility.
If you want blind users to be able to use
your app, or even just people who are using
accessibility type features to make it more
easy, then having those touch target selectors
is really important.
>>Chung: Before going to any of these, let's
have a quick look at the menu.
There's help, settings, the items that, the
usual suspects, basically, things that you
would expect to see under the overflow menu.
>>Meier: Absolutely.
I want to point out, as well here, that looking
at this main screen here as well, you can
see that we've actually got an action bar,
which is good.
But in this case, I think actually it would
make a lot of sense to have an action bar
which was perhaps translucent, because you've
got this whole screen effect here where it's
this immersive thing, completely custom controls.
The action bar almost looks a little bit plunked
on top.
Perhaps changing the color of your action
bar to match the background or have a translucent
action bar would be an interesting design
choice.
>>Chung: I actually like the suggestion on
translucent.
Let's have a look at the recipe screens.
As you can see, in this drop down box, there
are different types of occasions like starter,
sides, dinner, whatever.
There are different categories that you can
choose from.
It prepopulates it with a bunch of delicious
dishes.
>>Meier: [laughs] Absolutely.
>>Chung: You can swipe food, the selection
of dishes.
These are the top level recipe items.
What you can do is look at the various ingredients
and the steps involved in the preparation
of the dish.
What I would suggest is that when you have
a tablet, the most probable use case is someone
using your app in a kitchen.
I might be sitting three to four feet away
from the tablet.
The font size as it stands is a little bit
too small.
>>Meier: Yeah, it is, it's a little small.
>>Chung: I'm having a hard time in reading
the text.
>>Meier: Exactly.
What you want to really have is so that you
can set up the tablet on your kitchen bench,
probably a little further away from the food--
>>Chung: Definitely.
>>Meier: --and sources of heat [laughs] than
you would want otherwise.
You really want to be able to see this text
from a good five to ten feet away, assuming
you have a bigger kitchen than me.
>>Chung: Have a look at the overflow menu.
I wish they had an option where you can increase
the font size, but it, at least, I can't find
it from here.
What's interesting is that for each step,
you can go in and edit it.
Sometimes people like to deviate.
>>Meier: That's nice.
Absolutely.
There's not a recipe that I use that I haven't
modified slightly.
>>Chung: Exactly.
>>Meier: You know what else would be really
nice here, I don't know if there's any support
for it, but to have the ability to add pictures
for each step.
I find that's really useful if I know if it
looks the way it's supposed to, if I've done
things the right way.
Like when they say "brown it", how brown is
it supposed to be?
Those sorts of things would be really nice.
A picture of the finished product and also
a picture of each step.
>>Chung: Great suggestion.
You can capture it for motivation.
>>Meier: Absolutely.
This is what I would do: I would do the recipe
and I would take a photo of each step so I
was able to see the process of going through.
And potentially, even the ability to add a
video.
If I record the whole thing of how it all
went.
I see we've got Roman on screen.
What do you think, Roman?
If you've had a chance to look at this app,
what are your thoughts from the UI perspective?
>>Roman Nurik: I haven't had a chance to take
a full look, but just from looking at what
you guys are showing now, the same common
problems that we see everywhere are showing
up in this app.
And they're not really problems, it's just
I think probably the lack of a tablet-optimized
UI inside a tablet.
One thing I wanted to mention was just on
the very home screen, I guess the top level
screen, that has that massive dashboard, I
just wanted to make a shout out for, I guess,
against dashboards and using dashboards, especially
on tablets.
There are lots and lots of different ways
you can show a top level screen.
Some of those ways are actually listed in
our design guidelines under the app structure
pattern.
I definitely recommend taking a look there
to see how you can get away from a dashboard.
You don't necessarily have to completely remove
the dashboard, but one thing you could do
is potentially include content break there,
so when you're showing the big icons, the
big buttons, to get into the section, show
the preview of the content that you're about
to see when you tap into that section.
It's just one of the things that--
>>Chung: Some pictures, right.
Some pictures of the dishes that you're trying
to prepare.
That's great.
Let's go back to recipes.
As I was testing this application, I tried
to add a new dish.
At first, I thought, this "Add" button represented
it, but instead--
>>Meier: That's a step within the existing
recipe.
>>Chung: Right, right.
But instead, what I was looking for is hidden
in the overflow menu.
>>Meier: Oh, I see.
>>Chung: "New recipes."
So I think it would be great to expose this
feature on the action bar if there's space.
>>Meier: Yeah, definitely.
I think there is plenty of space in the action
bar for that.
"Add recipes" seems like it would be one of
the main features of what you want to do within
an app like this.
Absolutely.
>>Chung: Let's have a quick look at "shopping
list."
You can have various shopping lists associated
with the recipes that we looked at.
Let's say you've decided on what to cook for
dinner.
Then you can quickly transfer the list of
items into your shopping list.
I think it's a good use case where at home,
the user might be using a tablet to come up
with the list of recipes, and then, based
on the list of recipes, you come up with a
shopping list.
Then if you support something like syncing
with the Cloud, when you take your Android
device out, you can have the shopping list
with you at the grocery store, where it can
mark off various items.
>>Meier: Do you know if this has the ability
to sync?
Like, are you signing in at any point?
If I have my tablet, which lives in my kitchen,
or at least in my living room and kitchen,
to be able to do recipes, can I sync that
up with my phone so I have my shopping list
with me?
>>Chung: I think there was, but I can't recall.
But assuming it does, I think it would be
a good use case.
>>Meier: Definitely.
Nice.
That would be my wish list.
I think, for me, to just go ahead and start
using this would be pictures, lots of pictures.
Food, eating, and preparing food: a big part
of that is visual.
Being able to see what the cauliflower cheese
soup looks like is going to make it much more
likely for me to actually create it.
Certainly, whenever I'm using cookbooks and
recipes, seeing that picture of what it's
going to end up like is a big thing for me.
>>Chung: Definitely.
I will also say that for this kind of app,
where initially, there's a bunch of data entry
involved, you might want to think of ways
to make it easier for users, because I imagine
if it becomes too cumbersome to enter a lot
of text, you will experience a lot of drop
offs.
You may think of ways to maybe support upscanning
for barcodes and stuff like that that would
make it a lot easier for users to use it.
Or, alternatively, you can have a lot more
prepopulated items for people to just pick
and choose from an existing list.
That would make the user experience better.
>>Meier: Yeah.
In fact, thinking this through, that's probably
the way I would start to use this.
Right now at home, I have this big folder
with recipes which I've pulled out of newspapers
and photocopied from people and printed out
emails.
I'm probably not going to want to enter all
of that in straight away.
My first step would just be to photograph
each one.
Just give it a title and then scan in the
picture.
Then I can always go through and actually
populate the fields separately, later.
>>Chung: We're getting the app.
>>Meier: We're getting the app.
>>Chung: There's the sign.
>>Meier: We have 35 seconds left to go.
>>Chung: We have a new prop here.
>>Meier: We have a gong, too.
We want to run out the time just so we can
have the gong go.
It's very important.
[laughs] I think we should actually just wait
22 seconds--
>>Chung: Yeah, let's do it.
>>Meier: --until it goes off, but let's see.
We've got the categories here.
We've got everything else.
It's actually looking pretty good.
Why don't you gong us out, Ian?
>>Chung: Awesome.
All right.
That's our signal.
>>Meier: I really hope that that was audible.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Look, it just came off.
>>Chung: Wow, how did that happen?
>>Meier: [laughs]
>>Chung: Oh, great.
All in all, it's a great start.
It looks like the development team is a pretty
small team.
>>Meier: Absolutely.
If guys are watching, if you hear about this,
then do reach out to us, and we'll try and
help to give you that extra feedback to help
really make this into our go-to recipe app.
>>Chung: Definitely.
>>Meier: Now, I don't want to cut Fred off
here, but I didn't really think this through,
because I haven't had lunch, and looking at
recipes is making me hungry.
So let's switch across and have a look at
one of these other apps.
>>Chung: Sure.
>>Meier: That work for you?
All right.
Let's restart our time.
I will try to be a little more conscious of
time.
>>Chung: Which one do we want to look at?
>>Meier: I want to have a look at Series Guide.
This is an app I use quite a lot of.
I think it was actually Roman who put me on
to this.
You a Series Guide user as well, Roman?
>>Nurik: I am, I absolutely am.
I think this app is one of my favorites for
tracking episodes and TV shows.
>>Chung: Awesome.
Let's switch to the tablet.
>>Meier: Cool.
Yeah, let's have a look at the tablet view.
One--.
These are some of my favorite apps.
I'm going to be particularly, not harsh, but
I'm going to have a pretty high bar for some
of the comments that I have here for them.
One of the big kicks that I'm on at the moment
is trying to create apps that present a magical
experience.
Apps that you're not really thinking about
them running on a phone, you're not thinking
about the internet connection, you're not
thinking about anything other than the functionality
that they provide.
That's the basis around which I'm going to
be providing some of this feedback.
If you look on the getting started guide right
here, we're asked to choose our primary content
language.
We have the ability to connect to a social
network associated with it, and an option
to send developer usage statistics.
This is all fair enough, but the problem with
it is it's straight away.
I open the app and I'm presented with all
of this text, all of these choices.
Generally speaking, I find it much better
if you just load up the app and it straightaway
dumps you into whatever it is that the app
is supposed to do.
So I would suggest to the developers here
to actually see if you can remove all of this
on startup so that you're just able to get
straight into the gear.
I'm a little concerned about what I'm hearing
over my shoulder, but we'll continue.
[laughs]
>>Nurik: The other thing I want to mention
is when you just get into an app, usually,
you're presented--.
Or, in apps that are just list views or just
where the primary content pane is basically
empty because you haven't done anything in
the app yet, there's no need to present a
dialog.
Just present any sort of introductory material
like "stuff that you do happens here" right
in line.
There's a big opportunity to use the empty
view.
When your list view has no items in it, use
the empty view to be more visual.
Do so right in line in the content [indistinct]
dialog if you're going to do it at all.
>>Meier: Yeah, I totally agree.
In fact, if we dismiss this here, we get exactly
that.
We get this massive pane of emptiness, which
just says, "No shows here."
Now, what we're supposed to do is start adding
in the shows that we are interested in watching.
You do that by hitting the "plus" button,
which makes total sense.
And then we can start searching for shows.
Now, what you'll also notice, that here you've
got this "trending" tab, which shows you a
bunch of shows which other people have been
looking for.
Now, there's a bunch of these that I actually
do want to track.
Now, I don't know, what do you think, Roman?
For me, I would love to see basically that
intro screen being all of the trending shows,
which I can then just go in and add right
off the bat.
That's the way you get started, is by seeing
a whole bunch of suggestions based on what
other people have been adding, and have that
ability to just go, "Yeah, Breaking Bad, plus.
Game of Thrones, plus.
Dexter, plus."
>>Chung: Make it easier to add--
>>Nurik: Absolutely.
>>Meier: And then straight away, you understand
what it is that the show is offering.
So again, here we have this big dialog explaining
what the show is, giving us the synopsis and
the ability to add.
Now, that's useful, and I would certainly
like to have that as a plus, but in the instance
here, I'd even more so prefer just a bunch
of "plus" buttons along this outer edge so
that I can just say, "Well, I know what Breaking
Bad is.
I've been watching it for the past five years.
I just want to add it without having to read
about it."
>>Chung: The pop up [indistinct]
>>Meier: Exactly.
>>Nurik: Interesting.
The other thing is that the way this is listed,
the way shows are listed it this app, is they're
basically listed as a list.
Vertical list of things.
Whereas with really media-friendly stuff like
content, or, I guess, media-rich content presenting,
the grid is generally just better.
Leaves you more space to show nice big photos.
If you even overlay the titles over the photos
so that everything, almost every pixel in
the screen is covered by content, that's generally
better than presenting just a list of thumbnail
on the left and text on the right.
>>Chung: Small thumbnail.
There are one day of defeat that they're getting
from if they have bigger assets.
>>Meier: They do, they absolutely do.
In fact, it's one of the strengths of this
app.
>>Chung: If you do, take advantage of it.
>>Meier: Let's go back to the main menu.
I've added a bunch of shows, and you can see
straight away that they're already presenting
something better here.
Once you go to the shows that you've already
included, you get the back route view which
Roman was talking about.
But even here, I'd say there's an opportunity
here to use that space more, to use bigger
assets, so this becomes a really visual experience.
Having the images associated with the shows
is, I think, a really powerful thing.
I would consider making that a much bigger
part of each grid item.
Very much along the lines of what Roman was
suggesting.
The point here is that it's telling us when
our next episode of all of these shows are
coming up.
We have a bunch of options that we can choose
too.
If you go into settings, we have this wall
of settings which allow us to do things like--.
And they show episodes which have already
been on before, which reduces my list, which
makes me sad.
[laughs] But you can see exactly what's coming.
And then you can go into each of the shows,
Game of Thrones, and then you get all the
details, the director's guest stars, what
episodes are on or coming.
You can see here, in the background, you've
got the big graphic, right?
>>Chung: Yeah.
>>Nurik: Yeah.
>>Meier: Not coming across as well as that
one.
>>Chung: What does "check in" do?
Just real quick.
>>Meier: "Check in", I think, if you're logged
into Trakt, or possibly not, it lets you basically
have that social aspect, where you're checking
into the show.
>>Chung: Oh, interesting.
I was looking at this feature right here--
>>Meier: If you're watching it, you check
in as part of that.
Have you actually used that at all, Roman?
>>Nurik: No, I don't use the check in as much.
I know this is a growing, more popular interaction,
to actually check into shows as they come
on, but I haven't used them myself.
It is a very popular thing with services like
GetGlue and I believe Trakt as well, but I
haven't used it.
>>Meier: Yeah.
I guess it's around that whole second screen
experience idea, where you're socializing
while you're watching TV.
I struggle with it because I very seldom watch
TV live.
I'm always time shifting it and watching it
at least an hour or so later.
>>Chung: Yeah, like the Olympics.
>>Meier: [laughs] Well, the Olympics is not
by choice.
But this is not the forum for me to rant,
because I don't have enough time to explain
exactly how I feel about the NBC cover job
of the Olympics.
>>Chung: I was just pointing out that similarity.
>>Meier: [laughs] Absolutely.
Yeah.
The other thing which I have to say about
this app--.
Like I say, Roman suggested this to me.
I use it a lot now.
But one of the things I struggled with when
I first started the app is that it wasn't
immediately obvious to me how everything worked.
The plus icon being "add show," it wasn't
immediately obvious to me that that's what
it was going to do.
I didn't necessarily understand the work flow.
So I think that's something which would be
really great to be simplified and better explained.
I think giving me that list of suggestions
right off the bat is going to help.
But help me through the work flow, make it
more obvious what I need to do at each point,
and that will make it easier for me to use
all the features.
>>Chung: In the action bar, they have a mix
of text and icons for the action items.
Maybe they can--.
This is actually combined, activity with a
clock icon and a search icon.
>>Meier: Yeah.
It does have the tiny little vertical separators.
Actually, no.
There's a missing vertical separator between
"plus" and "activity", which is really confusing.
It looks like it's the same thing.
>>Chung: It wasn't apparent to me that the
clock icon actually represents it's tied to
the activity text.
>>Meier: Search-- Okay, so it's the right
search icon.
I mean, generally speaking, they've done things
well.
But I'd also be really cautious about things
like your settings menu where there are a
lot of things here.
Advanced and everything else.
You may consider--.
This is actually using the old preference
activities rather than the new preference
fragments.
There are a few options that you have here
to actually separate things into categories,
make it a little bit easier to dissect.
I'd want to have things like advanced and
more almost off in a separate category so
it's not confusing the rest of it.
Because this is a little bit intimidating.
You've been using it longer than I have, Roman.
Do you have any particular suggestions that
you'd like to point out about what they do
well or what they could do a little bit better?
>>Nurik: Yeah.
I think when this app just came out, it was
using the default demon.
A lot of my comments are visual, so this would
be visual feedback.
But before, I guess a couple months ago, this
app was using the default stock hollow theme.
Everything was hollow, blue and everything.
That was good.
I think that, obviously, you do want to modify,
you do want to brand it a little bit.
In this case, I feel like the branding is--
that neon purple-- it doesn't really mesh
all that well with the rest of the hollow
UI, the hollow style.
For example, all the window backgrounds are
using the default hollow gradient from black
to a dark gray Then the neon purple on top
of that doesn't seem to really mesh well.
What I would do is I would probably go through
and clean up some of the UI.
I feel like there are some parts that are
really remnants of the default hollow style.
Just make sure to either customize more, dark
and branded, custom UI isn't as great as it
could be.
It's definitely better than a lot of the other
apps that we've seen, but that could be improved.
Another thing is--.
This is very specific, but when you get into
an episode of a show, there's actions at the
top right, like "search" and "favorite" and
"share", and then there's actions right in
the middle of the screen.
One of the--
>>Meier: Yeah.
"Check in", etc.
[buzzing sound]
>>Nurik: Yeah.
I find that little strange.
I think it violates one of the core rules
of putting things near the corners, near the
edges.
It's a little easier to find, a little easier
to discover, unless the in line actions are
really obvious.
In this case, I feel like they're buried under
the content.
One thing that I do really often is mark a
show as watched.
I feel like it's buried in a sea of text.
That's one thing that I would try to do.
If you do have actions that are in line, make
sure that they're more visible, that they're
more prominent, that they stand out apart
from the content that surrounds it, because
otherwise, it may not be obvious, it may be
difficult to locate.
>>Meier: Cool.
Yeah, I totally agree.
I think for a lot of those, it would make
sense to just have them in the action bar.
Because as you said, they're primary actions.
Having watched a show.
Our gong has gone off, so we're going to have
to move on.
But I think that's some interesting advice.
I think the key things here is that visually,
I think they could do a lot more with what
they've got.
More images, more grids, more density of color
and imagery.
And similarly, as well, I think, just to give
a couple of examples from what Roman was saying,
and hopefully he'll agree, I think in terms
of customized branding, if you have a look
at an app like-- GeekBeat does a really good
job of that.
They have their own custom color schemes,
which is throughout the entire app, and it's
consistent.
Tasks and Tasks Free are a good example of
an app which you're actually using very much
the standard paradigms.
>>Ni-Lewis: Hey guys.
Producer Ian here.
We just wanted to mention that one of our
viewers took a look at the page for my Food,
and it turns out that they have-- Actually,
you know what?
You guys should be looking at the camera.
There we go.
Now we can talk directly to each other.
Hi, Reto and Fred!
>>Meier: Hi, Ian.
>>Chung: Hey, we haven't seen you for a while.
Where are you calling from?
>>Ni-Lewis: Nice.
Yeah.
I'm calling from right over here.
Whoo!
Anyway, I suppose that's a really neat comment,
which was that actually, you guys mentioned
something about it was a little bit sparse,
not too many graphics, stuff like that.
It turns out there was a user request for
a sparse interface and the dev responded really
quickly to that and made that.
It sounds like maybe it should have been an
option rather than a default, though.
>>Meier: It sounds like some of that--.
It actually brings up a really interesting
point, particularly if you're creating an
app which is quite popular.
It's going to be impossible to satisfy all
of your users.
Me and Fred can sit here and have exactly
the opposite opinions about the same app.
And certainly, once you get more than a couple
of thousand downloads, you're going to have
the same problem.
One thing you can do there is use analytics
a lot to figure out how people are actually
using your app.
You can do things like institute options where
you have "show images, don't show images"
and find out which people are using more.
Try and build your user interface around that.
Definitely something you want to consider
is, before doing those radical changes, is
to think about how people are using the app,
and give them the option to pick one or the
other before deciding which is the best approach.
>>Chung: Right.
Or, if you have resources, think about doing
things like AB testing to see which one--
>>Meier: Absolutely.
>>Chung: --users react to better.
That's great.
And also, it's good to see that you're reacting
to user comments as well.
>>Meier: Yeah.
Absolutely, absolutely.
Cool.
All right.
Let's have a look at your next app.
>>Chung: The next app is called BigOven.
It's, like I said before, it's another app
that consists of a lot of recipes where it
tries to give you some ideas on what's for
dinner, what's for lunch, and stuff like that.
You're able to identify the items and create
shopping lists based on the recipes.
>>Meier: Nice.
I like the fact that they've got a tablet
layout right off the bat.
This is making me happy.
>>Chung: They have a tablet layout, two pane
layouts with a big logo here.
What stands out initially is that I see two
search functions here.
You have a duplication of features on the
very same screen, so you can think of maybe
eliminating one.
Maybe there's a specific reason why you decided
to include both.
It's not--.
But it feels duplicate.
Duplicated feature.
Let's do a search on something.
>>Meier: What's your favorite recipe?
>>Chung: Something that has to do with beef.
>>Meier: Beef?
[laughs] You're not a real developer.
If you were a real Android developer, it would
have been bacon.
>>Chung: Test.
There you go.
So it shows you, whoa.
A bunch of pictures.
These are user generated contents with star
ratings.
You can--.
Let's say go.
Pick one, beef and chili with beans.
Loading recipes to the latency.
>>Meier: I was going to say, if we just drop
back once, this is a really good example of
an app which is using that visualness to really
draw you in.
You've just got this wall of beef, which could
be quite intimidating.
But in this case, it's just making me really
hungry.
I do notice that it tends to be a little bit
slow in terms of, particularly this loading
the recipe.
Bringing the images in here slowly, that's
reasonable, although it feels like, based
on the speed here, it feels like we're pulling
down images much bigger than the thumbnail
being displayed.
If you're pulling them down from a server
and then shrinking them, try and have those
shrunken assets on the server so you're just
pulling down as little as possible.
And things like this.
The loading more recipes: try and pre-cache
a little more aggressively.
You should have at least a scroll's worth
of data queued up so that you don't feel that
lag.
>>Chung: All right.
When you go back--
>>Meier: This is unacceptable.
You really need to find ways to cache your
images.
You will, for memory reasons, likely still
have to dump them out of your cache in terms
of your memory cache and display them, but
it shouldn't take this long to put them back
in.
>>Chung: Yeah.
If you want to know specific technical tips
on how to do it, we have a training class
on Android training that specifically talks
about loading bitmaps and caching and stuff
like that.
Check it out.
>>Nurik: Actually, I think Adam Kash from
Martina's clinic adds some updates to that.
And another thing I wanted to point out is
that in the Google IO application, which is
now open-sourced, a bunch of new stuff related
to image caching is there as well.
You can rip stuff right out of there.
I believe we're updating the Android training
article on that as well.
>>Meier: Awesome.
All right, let's get back into the beef and
chili with beans.
>>Chung: Beef and chili.
See the loading latency.
I think there's--
>>Meier: It's a little slow, right?
>>Chung: Yeah, it's pretty slow.
>>Meier: When I was talking beforehand about
creating a magical app, that's a big part
of it for me.
Every time you see the loading dialog or a
blank thing which needs to be populated or
fill up, it breaks the magic.
It ruins that suspension to disbelief.
You remember that, "Oh, this app needs to
connect to an internet source and pull down
this data and populate this view."
I don't want to be made aware of any of that,
I just want it to magically happen as though
this were some crazy magic box of the future
which had every recipe in the world somehow
contained within it.
This looks nice.
The UI here is definitely--
>>Chung: Yeah, it's pretty clean.
Well, I like to repeat the feedback that we
gave.
>>Meier: Yeah.
Bigger text.
>>Chung: Bigger text.
But I think this particular app, there's an
option where you can increase the font size,
which is great.
There are different tabs, like "recipe", "reviews",
and "photos"--
>>Meier: Excellent.
Of photos.
>>Chung: --of various-- And again, latency,
I don't know what's going on here.
We have a pretty fast network here.
[laughs]
>>Meier: [laughs] You definitely want to be
downloading those photos.
I rather suspect that the photos are bigger
than they need to be.
You're pulling--.
And I noticed, also, they all came in at once
here.
Again, it's the same sort of ideas of making
sure you download more than you, download
progressively and make sure that you're optimizing
those downloads to pull down as little as
you need.
>>Nurik: Actually, can I make a comment here
on the UI?
>>Chung: Certainly.
>>Meier: Of course.
>>Nurik: There is one thing I wanted to mention.
This is just happening over and over again.
I feel like every app we look at on the tablet
has this issue.
White space.
There's just--.
It's a much better use of white space than
lots of the other apps we've seen, but still.
It could be improved.
Like you guys mentioned, increase in font
sizes, things like that, will help.
One trick that I find useful when trying to
optimize my white space is to take a screenshot
of my app as is and start shrinking it down
gradually.
Shrink it down to about 25%, to even 10% of
its original size and look at that.
If you can still pick out your white space
from the text, and if it doesn't look even,
if it doesn't seem like there's a natural
balance in the negative space and the actual
text and content, then you probably have a
white space problem.
Try to think of how you can better fill out
the white space, but don't pack in text into
the white space.
White space is still important.
But make sure that it's balanced.
That's just one trick.
Shrink it down and see if there's something
that seems wrong in that shrunken version.
>>Meier: I had a question, actually, related
to that.
If you have a look at this main search results
page, where you have all of these things.
I like that there's lots of images there.
We do still have those gaps between.
I know that one of the UI trends that I've
seen a lot of lately is basically removing
all of those borders and having basically
zero margins between images.
>>Chung: Wall of pictures.
>>Meier: Yeah.
Is that something you think would work well
here?
>>Nurik: Yeah, I think that can definitely
work well in a lot of cases.
In this case, since the background is white,
I personally find that having this zero pixel
border, text overlaid on top of images, works
really well if the rest of the background--.
I guess the theme of the app is hollow dark,
or just a darker theme.
Otherwise, the white will really stand out.
Actually, one thing that this app may want
to consider doing is trying that.
Trying that wall of images with very little
space in between and having the text overlaid
on top of the images.
But then try to switch the theme so that the
left pane is not so bright.
The contrast will be way too high if you have
that kind of wall of images and don't change
the background.
>>Meier: That's a good point.
That's the other thing I was going to suggest
as well.
As Fred pointed out, I'm not sure if we can
empty the screen.
This is how we get to when we open up the
app.
Again, the whole point of a recipe app is
to make me hungry, make me want to cook stuff.
It seems to me like this would be a great
opportunity to put something here in this
big empty space, right from the beginning.
The most popular apps--.
Or, sorry, the most popular recipes, or your
favorite recipes, or featured recipes, random
recipes, basically anything.
Because you have a random recipe button, right?
>>Chung: Why don't you just default it?
>>Meier: Exactly.
Well, no, it's an actual--
>>Chung: Or maybe a big picture--
>>Meier: Yeah.
Or have a recipe or have a bunch of random
recipes.
But something which is going to inspire you,
so that as soon as you open this up, you're
like, "Oh, yeah, actually, that looks like
something I might like to create."
>>Nurik: It's almost like within zero clicks--.
Assume you get featured on Google Play, you
installed the app, and you press the open
button.
Without doing anything else, the user should
think, "Wow, I'm definitely keeping this app."
>>Meier: Exactly.
Exactly right.
Maybe "recent raters" is perfect.
Yes.
This is what I would start with.
These are the recipes that most people have
been raving about.
If I open the app straight--.
It was featured on Google Play, I hit install,
open, boom, and this is what I saw?
Suddenly, I have much more incentive than
just from seeing this big logo.
I can be like, "Oh, those Oreo bowls look
phenomenal."
[laughs] Straight away, it's like, "I don't
need much for that.
I've got cream cheese and Oreos.
I'm pretty much already sold."
Straight away, you're scrolling through things.
And again, getting really hungry.
Which is, again, why we want to make sure
that you don't have this long load time of
each recipe clicking in.
I just want to be able to scroll through this
list and see anything which looks awesome,
and be like, "Oh wow, I totally need to make
skewered honey balsamic vinegar kebabs."
Wow, I need to stop.
[laughs]
>>Nurik: A commenter on HBC 2000 also mentions
this app might be a little more attractive
if they used the light hollow theme on the
action bar instead of the dark
>>Meier: That's true.
The consistency there is definitely an issue.
>>Chung: They have the default blue line here.
>>Meier: [laughs] With the red straight underneath.
>>Chung: The red line is part of their brand.
You can definitely theme a little bit.
>>Meier: Hmm.
Exactly.
Given that you do have this strong color branding,
you may want to consider using, changing the
color of your action bar to match the recipe
color branding.
That's definitely something you can do.
But I'm intrigued by Roman's idea of switching
the whole theme around to something dark and
then emphasizing the images more.
>>Chung: Definitely.
>>Meier: I'd also point out that the actual
text star that they're using there is a serif
font, which works really well if you're reading
a book or something like that, but it doesn't
work quite as well on computer screens, and
particularly when you're reading it from a
distance.
You'll notice most presentations tend to use
a sans-serif font like an Arial or a Helvetica
or something like that.
And again, you may be browsing it sitting
down on your couch, but you're going to be
using it in a kitchen on a stand, again, from
a distance.
So again, it's great that they let you bump
up the text size.
I would probably prefer here, either an option
or just a default, to be a sans-serif.
>>Chung: That's a good point.
>>Nurik: One of the other things I wanted
to mention on fonts is-- And this is unfortunate.
[gong sounds] We just, I guess if we just
didn't have time or if we didn't plan on it,
but the new font of Android, the new typeface,
is Roboto, obviously.
There's no serif version of Roboto, though.
>>Meier: That's interesting.
>>Nurik: Basically, a lot of the improvements,
a lot of the core image and design philosophy
of Android is around the typography.
So you're missing a lot of that by using Android
serif.
Having said that, there's also Roboto Thin
and Roboto Light.
When you have text that's larger, let's say
in the 30 or the 40 sps, Roboto Light can
really give it a sense of class or elegance.
Coupled with increasing the font size, you
may want to consider using the different weights
of Roboto.
There are several.
Actually, as of Jelly Bean, we bundle very,
very many weights of Roboto, so you have more
options.
Or you can just bundle the TTF directly here
if you can.
>>Meier: Outstanding.
Cool.
That was our gong in the background, so we're
ready to move on to our next app, which is
one of mine.
TripIt's hard to demo without having some
trips in there.
We've only got a few minutes, so let's have
a look at IMDb instead.
Based on the two apps that I've looked at
today, you can get a fair idea of how I enjoy
to spend some of my spare time.
But I'm a big fan of the IMDb app.
This is a great example of an app which users--.
It's very much its own custom branding.
This doesn't look like hollow.
It doesn't not look like it either.
But it definitely looks like IMDb.
We have this consistent gray gradient branding
with the quite distinctive IMDb gold logo.
And again, if we look at what we've been talking
about so far with today's apps, we load this
up and straight away, I'm presented with a
wall of images.
I've got video front and center and a scrolling
marquee.
I've got another scrolling marquee down here
of awesome-looking movie posters.
Coming soon is the same.
This is basically full of imagery.
That, I think, it makes for a really compelling
experience, because straight away, you've
got things to look at, you've got things to
scroll, you've got things to browse.
Overall, I quite like that.
It's not a standard action bar, because it's
too high to be a standard action bar.
They've done some interesting things here,
like this overflow menu is clearly not a default
of the standard overflow menu, or even a standard
pop up menu, which a lot of people use to
simulate that effect.
I don't know.
To me, it almost works in that it's got the
branding, it's got the gray and the gold,
which is obviously the theme they're going
throughout, but the weird rounded corners
and the drop shadow strikes me as being a
little off.
This is the first time where I click something
on the app, and suddenly, it doesn't quite
feel like a native app anymore.
What do you think, Roman?
>>Nurik: Yeah, I do want to call out, like
you said, the drop shadows, also some of the
gradients, like the title bar or rather the
fake action bar has this stark gradient.
One of the things we generally recommend,
This is not like a "You must not use gradients
on Android" or anything, but we definitely
recommend using fewer visual effects.
Things like drop shadows, things like gradients,
things like glosses.
They clash with the minimalistic, cleaner
style of hollow.
When a user gets their Galaxy Nexus or one
of their ICS devices, they're presented with
somewhat minimal UI apps.
Apps that give you content and minimize the
number of pixels that are dedicated purely
to aesthetics of the Chrome, of the surrounding
elements of the app.
Definitely minimizing that and using some
of the simpler, minimal styles would make
more sense, I think.
Then definitely using the stock action bar
and tweaking the styles.
Like you can make that--.
If you absolutely needed that bar to be taller,
you could tweak that using styles.
You don't have to reimplement the action bar.
>>Meier: In fact, I'd suggest that they probably
don't need to make it taller.
It just feels stretched for no really good
reason.
I like that they've used the standard search
widget here.
That's great.
These keys here, "movies", "TV", "celebs",
that, again, strikes me as a little odd, because
they're not really action so much as navigation
cues.
As per the Android stands, I'd expect them
to be over on the left-hand side over here,
next to the IMDb logo.
Similarly, I expect this to behave like a
standard action bar.
I'm looking for an up caret on the left here
so that I can return to this, to the main
page.
The navigation actually works the way it should,
but I'm missing some of those standard queues
that I'm really used to seeing.
I'd like to see these as default, regular
tabs or something similar to that, rather
than being actions when they're not really
actions.
>>Chung: The general pattern goes on the action
bar on the left hand side.
You have the icon followed by a navigation
control.
Put everything else, like the action menu
items, on the right-hand side.
>>Meier: Exactly.
Things like "search," they've got in exactly
the right place.
Having all this stuff in the overflow menu,
again, makes sense.
I want to highlight, as well, here, that they
have the ability to sign in.
You can have an IMDb account and sign in.
Presumably, things like your watch list, some
ratings history, and the ratings you provide
are all then going to be part of it.
What a lot of apps do wrong is that they don't
let you use anything until you've signed in.
When you install it off Google Play, hit open,
the first thing you're presented with is this
sign in screen.
That's a real off-putter, because it's like,
"Well, I've not even looked at this app yet.
I have no idea what it wants, and it wants
credentials, it wants me to create an account.
I want to know what I'm getting into first."
So I love that about this app, in that it
lets you experience the full app.
It's not until you want to do something which
requires you to sign in that it actually asks
you to do so.
It also lets you do so as well here in the
overflow menu.
That style of presenting as much as you can,
and then having additional features as an
incentive to actually sign in, I think it's
a really good pattern.
>>Chung: Great point.
>>Meier: Let's have a look.
Otherwise, it works pretty much as you'd expect
it to.
Let's have a look at Total Recall, a movie
remake which fills me with dread.
I'm a huge fan of Philip K. Dick.
The movie implementations are usually pretty
questionable.
Total Recall, again, is a movie I really enjoyed
when I was younger, but--
>>Off-camera engineer: [Terminator voice]
It's not a tumor!
>>Meier: [laughs] That may be the wrong Schwarzenegger
movie, but nonetheless.
I always wondered about Schwarzenegger in
the lead role of that.
Colin Farrell is a better match, but I don't
know.
I'm apprehensive, to say the very least, about
this remake.
In any case, you can see here, as soon as
we navigate in, again, we have a wall of pictures.
We have a big image of the movie poster.
We see the top bill cast.
They're all here on the left.
We have galleries.
These aren't scrollable, so I guess you have
to hit "all" to see more of the images.
This is interesting.
They've got this pop up dialog.
I hate, hate, hate pop up dialogs, particularly
when there's no obvious way to dismiss it.
I'm going to guess that the back button does
the job.
But I don't know.
I feel like this could be done a little bit
neater.
I like that--
>>Chung: You could do it in place.
>>Meier: --to be scrollable here.
Just let me scroll through.
>>Chung: Yeah, I saw your first inclination
on this section of the screen was to scroll.
>>Meier: Yeah, exactly, because they used
marquees elsewhere in the app, so I'd like
to be able to just flick through here and
see all the cast without having to change
contexts.
Same with the gallery.
If I click on an image, it actually goes to
the artist's page.
That all makes sense.
>>Chung: Let's check out how sharing is done
in this app.
>>Meier: Done the right way.
>>Chung: As expected.
That's great.
>>Meier: Right icons, that's all nice.
As you can see, they've really taken this
custom styling to the final degree.
Everything is custom.
These dialogs don't look like normal Android
dialogs.
They're quite tall.
They've got the action, not the action bar,
but the title bar on top.
Now, there's nothing wrong with customizing
the look and feel of these sorts of things,
but particularly dialogs, which, our general
guidance is to use dialogs only when you're
doing a system level thing.
That's when you pop up the dialog.
It's like when WiFi is being disabled or if
you want user authentication.
Something which is more than just the app,
beyond the context of the app, that's really
the only time you should be using dialogs.
If you're doing that, then they should look
like the system dialogs so that people know
what to expect.
Here, What I would say is that rather than
saying you should be using standard dialogs,
which would, in fairness, look really weird
on top of their custom UI, is see if you can
get out of using dialogs at all.
Whether doing things in place or having a
different fragment switch out, some other
way of navigating which doesn't pop something
on top of what you're doing.
Do you hate dialogs as much as I do?
>>Chung: Not quite.
>>Meier: Not as much?
>>Chung: I agree with your assessment in this
particular scenario where if this implementation
wasn't in place, transition would be better.
It felt like I was focusing on the right-hand
side of the screen.
If the dialog pops, it just breaks the continuity.
>>Meier: What about you, Roman?
In the couple of minutes we've got remaining?
>>Nurik: I generally agree.
I generally hate dialogs.
I, more than anything, hate progress and loading
dialogs.
>>Meier: Oh, yeah, well, they are the devil,
clearly.
>>Nurik: [laughs] In this case, I think the
dialog is really just a shortcut.
I feel like in a lot of cases when a developer
doesn't really have a great idea of what's
the best possible way to present something,
a dialog is a shortcut.
I've definitely done it myself.
I've definitely just said, "Oh, just make
it a dialog."
But definitely, a more complete, a better
solution would be just another fragment gliding
in, or something of that nature.
It's tough to avoid dialogs always because
they're very tempting.
But do try to avoid them.
>>Meier: Yeah.
That's a really good point.
Dialogs do represent, often, a shortcut.
It's a way of being able to, as a developer,
when you haven't really thought through all
of the work flows, it's like, "I need to present
this information.
How can I do that?"
A dialog is the easiest.
It's like doing a print line as a debugging--
>>Chung: It's like a catch all.
>>Meier: Exactly.
It's like using a toast to know whether or
not something's happened.
We all do that as part of our development
process.
Like, "Oh, the service has kicked off, so
I'm going to do a toast so I can see if it's
happened."
Then, by the time you actually go to production,
hopefully, you've removed all of those.
There's very few times you actually want to
toast.
Dialogs should be the same.
That's when you really want to bring in a
UX designer or someone like that who can figure
out how that information can be best displayed
to your users.
I think that pretty much takes us to the end
of our allotted time, if we want to give Dan
and Ian any chance of being able to prepare
in time to go on air.
Next week, what we've asked you guys to do
is to tell us some podcasting apps.
That's what we're looking for, is--.
All of our--.
We've got all of the Google IO sessions have
been turned into a podcast.
Same with all of the Office Hours shows that
we do on Wednesdays.
They're all available as podcasts.
Really, I want to know: what do you guys think
are the right apps that people should be using
to consume these?
That's what we're going to be looking at next
week.
Hopefully, if you guys suggest some podcasting
apps.
>>Chung: Hopefully we'll get some.
Not zero apps
>>Meier: Indeed.
I have a few which I use as well, so we will
be doing podcasting apps one way or the other.
It's either going to be the ones that we've
heard of and use, or it's going to be the
ones that you guys would like to see us talking
about.
Tune in for that.
The other thing that we have--.
This is a special request.
As you can see, we have a gong behind us.
As you can see, it is a gong that has been
optimized for a phone.
If anyone out there has a gong app, which
looks like a gong, and when you press it [gong
sounds]
>>Chung: It sounds like a gong.
>>Meier: It sounds like a gong.
We want to hear about it.
There's a opportunity here to either promote
your own app or build one specifically for
us.
It will be up here on the Friday App Clinic
every week.
That's the other reminder as well.
We have the App Clinic now, for those of us
who missed us at the beginning.
Hence the white coat.
We're really all about trying to look at the
things which apps are doing well, things which
apps are doing poorly, and try to help you
guys and developers understand how you can
build apps which are really great and provide
a magical experience.
So we're going to sign off.
We'll see you guys next Friday.
Thank you for joining us.
>>Chung: All right.
See you guys.